l'anthropologue dounia bouzar connaît
bien le phénomène de l'islam radical
dans un livre très éclairant il cherche
le paradis ils ont trouvé l'enfer elle
trace le portrait de ces djihadistes
occidentaux le livre relate plus
précisément l'itinéraire d'une jeune
française partis en syrie et pour qui la
vie a basculé
je me suis entretenu avec elle un peu
plus tôt madame beaux-arts bonsoir il
semble y avoir une explosion du nombre
d'aspirants djihadistes en europe
on a eu plusieurs cas de canadiens qui
ont joint les rangs du groupe armé états
islamiques et des noms à comprendre qui
sont ces jeunes touchés par ce discours
djihadistes bien justement le problème
c'est que ce discours djihadistes
terroristes jusqu'à ces dix dernières
années
arrivés plus tôt sensibiliser des jeunes
fragiles au niveau social et familial
des jeunes en perte d'espoir sociale
mais là il ya une mutation du discours
terroristes qui arrive à faire plusieurs
offres à des jeunes différents et à
faire basculer des jeunes complètement
différent c'est ça la nouveauté c'est
qu'il rentre dans des univers de jeunes
différents ils manipulent humanitaire il
utilise les techniques de dérives
sectaires
ils leur font miroiter une régénération
du monde qui serait plus juste
ils leur font miroiter d'être tout
puissant il ya plusieurs façons de faire
basculer des jeunes ce qui explique que
les jeunes sans être dans quelque chose
de très hiérarchique arrive à
intérioriser le discours chacun trouve
sa bonne raison de partir faire le
djihad par internet bien entendu oui
vous le dites l'embrigadement ne se fait
plus par les mosquées nécessairement
mais plutôt par internet par les réseaux
sociaux si ça nous on a une bonne
proportion de jeunes qui arrivent a
basculé à partir en irak sans avoir vu
de leur vie un seul musulman et sans
avoir mis les pieds une seule fois dans
les mosquées
puisque vous savez que ce nouveau
discours terroriste chez nous arrive à
toucher énormément de familles de
référence à thé qui ne sont absolument
pas d'origine arabo-musulmane et qui ne
sont pas du tout et
gray dont qu'ils arrivent vraiment a
touché toutes les classes sociales et
toutes les personnes quelles que soient
leurs origines ou leurs convictions et
comment peut-on repéré un jeune qui est
en train de se radicaliser
quels sont les signes visibles qui
doivent alerter les proches surtout pas
chercher de signes religieux de
visibilité religieuse
ce serait faire l'amalgamme avec les
musulmans et c'est ce que les
extrémistes recherche qu'on les prennent
pour de simples musulmans orthodoxes qui
ont leur liberté de culte et de
conscience
donc il faut chercher les indicateurs de
rupture très vite ils vont isoler le
jeune du reste du monde en lui disant
qu'il détient la vérité qu'il est
supérieur au reste du monde que il a un
discernement que les autres n'ont pas et
qu'il ne doit pas fréquenter ces autres
interlocuteurs
le jeune ne va plus fréquentes et ses
anciens amis en disant qu'ils sont un
pur va arrêter sa guitare et son
football en disant que c'est le diable
va arrêter l'école en disant que ça fait
partie du complot pour endormir les gens
et va avoir une rupture familiale
puisque le groupe va remplacer
l'autorité familiale
il faut donc compter les signes de
rupture c'est pour ça qu'on parle d'
utilisation des techniques des dérives
sectaires
parce qu'ils vont chercher à mettre le
jeune en auto exclusion pour que
justement avoir plus de pouvoir sur lui
sans que le jeune s'en rende compte
mais madame beaux-arts il ya eu dans le
passé des conflits qui ont attiré 10
djihadistes on peut penser à
l'afghanistan à l'irak
qu'est ce qui peut attirer de jeunes
occidentaux vers la syrie vers le groupe
armé état islamique qui fait preuve
d'une terrible brutalité d'une très
grande violence
alors je crois qu'on peut pas comparer
du tout le système terroristes mis en
place par filière en afghanistan dans le
passé et ce qui se passe là pour ce
pseudo état islamique l'a vraiment quand
je parle de mutation je crois que pour
faire de la prévention et faire de la
guérison
il faut vraiment se rendre compte que
les techniques ont changé et que il
rentre vraiment dans chaque pays dans
l'univers du jeune pour le
faire basculer que chacun a un motif
différent et c'est vrai que si on part
pas de sept de ses réalités qui sont
différentes on pourra pas les combattre
et vraiment l'afghanistan c'était très
politisé c'était géopolitique
là on ne dit pas aux jeunes qui vont
être terroriste
on dit aux jeunes au contraire qu'ils
vont régénérer le monde qu'ils sont élus
pour qu'on arrête ce monde où il y ait
des pauvres et des des gens puissants
qui garde la puissance pour eux on leur
dit qu'ils vont sauver les enfants gazés
par bachar el-assad qu'on va combattre
les soldats de bachar el-assad qui n'ont
pas été punis par la communauté
internationale on leur dit on leur dit
pas on est des terroristes qui extermine
le reste du monde et qui opéreront une
purification interne parce qu on
extermine aussi les musulmans syriens
qui ne font pas allégeance à notre
idéologie totalitaire c'est pas ça qu'on
dit aux jeunes
et justement pour les sortir de là il va
falloir montrer aux jeunes qui ils sont
vraiment des terroristes et justement
vous dites pour les sortir de là comment
prévenir cette radicalisation
vous avez cette loi en france qui
prévoit une interdiction de sortie du
territoire
au canada on retire le passeport est ce
que ce sont des mesures qui peuvent
contrer le phénomène alors il faut
savoir que quand on rentre dans une
idéologie de rupture comme celle ci on
ne n'appartient plus à aucune histoire
n'y a aucune nationalité ni même à sa
famille
c'est le groupe qui remplace la famille
c'est le groupe qui pensent à la place
de l'individu c'est c'est l'individu
n'existe plus c'est un embrigadement
donc je ne crois pas dans la menace de
retirer un passeport nous en france
c'est vrai qu'on a mis un système pour
essayer de les prendre avant qu'il ne
parte
sachant qu'une fois qu'ils ont été en
lien avec ces exactions innommable ils
sont de toutes façons traumatisés à vie
donc on essaye de les rattraper avant
c'est un système qui fonctionne parce
qu'on a énormément communiquer avec les
parents en disant voilà quand un enfant
arrête l'école c'est pas qu'il est trop
musulman c'est pa ti les deux
venu musulmans c'est un signe de rupture
donc en communiquant sur les signes de
rupture ce qu'on appelle des indicateurs
d' alerte l'ensemble de la chaîne
humaine en france s'est forgé et les
jeunes les parents les voisins les
professeurs les instituteurs les imams
les élus font la chaîne pour se mettre
d'accord à ce jeune est en danger
entraves aux droits de l'enfant on n'est
pas dans la liberté de conscience
on est dans la conscience capture est là
dans ce cas et ceux qui décident de
revenir de rentrer qu'est ce qui peut
être fait parce qu'après ce qu'ils ont
vécu c'est très difficile vous
l'expliqué bien dans votre livre
il cherchait le paradi's ont trouvé
l'enfer qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
de toute façon il ya une grande chance
qu'il revienne
la question c'est comment on provoque on
aide à la déradicalisation puisque le
jeune qui a été radicalisé l'a perdu son
cerveau il est dans une posture où c'est
le groupe qui pense à sa place donc loue
tout le travail qu'on essaye de mettre
en place avec nos premières expériences
de déradicalisation que ce soit pour un
jeune qui n'est pas encore parti on a
récupéré à temps où un jeune qui revient
ça va être justement d'enlever le robot
créé par le groupe terroriste et de
refaire revivre la personne humaine qui
étaient là on appelle ça remobiliser
l'individu en refaire quelqu'un qui
pense un sujet pensant pour ça on passe
par les affects et les témoignages
ça sert à rien de faire la morale à
quelqu'un qui pense qu'il a été élu pour
détenir la vérité est que les autres
sont jaloux parce que eux ne sont pas
élus vous pouvez pas vous placez sur le
domaine du savoir
donc on y va par des témoignages de
familles victimes par des gens qui ont
été victimes de cet endoctrinement et
qui on sonde endoctrinement au sens
embrigadement est ce que la personne se
sont jamais endoctrinés 1 et on fait on
passe par des témoignages pour montrer
aux jeunes
le décalage entre ce qu'on lui a vendu
et la réalité de ces groupuscules projet
de purification interne entre musulmans
projet d'extermination externe pour tous
ceux qui ne pensent pas comme eux
et rien à voir avec l'islam rien à voir
avec l'islam
on doit se laisser là dessus merci
beaucoup dounia bouzar de nous avoir
parlé ça nous permet de mieux comprendre
un phénomène qui est très inquiétant
merci beaucoup merci à vous